this questions and also the explanation
was a really good really good yeah very
good I think I am well I took I'm
missing English words yeah so for the
next topic because actually it is a big
problem if you if you once you move in a
natural language space are you see
there's so much new tag in it's great
and you see all it's all working in
English and I've tried myself it's
really it's not that easy to have this
working in German because most of the
research is actually in English I would
say Chinese so of course it's really
important to understand what your data
is evolved in which space you're working
and which features actually matter and
this brings me to our next talk I'm
really happy to have a Lisa here ELISA
is a data engineer at free now is it
called multi taxi at free now from
Hamburg so please give a warm welcome to
ELISA so hi there my name is ELISA as
Alex already mentioned I'm machine
learning engineer or data science
engineer is a different or older name
which suggests that I do mostly software
like Beck and engineering but very
specified and work with the models that
my peers produce and try to put them
production-ready into our system which
means I have to check that the model
itself is not several gigabytes so the
size that it's fast enough that the
feature engineering if we're talking
about model prediction on demand works
fast enough and old optimization things
from just the coding optimization up to
what data and how it's going in so let's
consider pipeline what is the normal
pipeline in general of machine learning
it's data collection first we're talking
about all possible data types
and formats then we prepare them so that
we can use it with the models also it
will depend the preparation step will
depend a bit on what you model intend to
use libraries for instance some
libraries just do not work with
timestamps in their normal form like
data type timestamp but they need to be
unwrapped into floats or whatever then
we are creating features these are
things that go into model directly from
the raw data you might use up to 10
percent or 400 percent of the data then
we do some sort of feature selection so
whoops I think I have lost my audience
hello so feature selection feature
engineering keine comes together in a
loop teacher selection is either when
you I don't know what's happening maybe
I'm stepping on something maybe testing
actually okay so then feature selection
is the features that introduce the most
important things to the model model
training manipulation and repeat over
again so this is the normal thing
visually it would look like this so you
collect everything you can of different
form and shapes you try to create the
proper input for our cow which is our
model and it produces the milk which is
our insights so we will be concentrating
on this three things technically feature
engineering feature selection and how
the model and feature selection can work
in a loop with each other I will pretty
create a small example here for this
Meetup I chose former one tables it is
the data is available on Hegel we will
try to predict given a small amount of
data whether these specific racer will
be in the top five for a race so
baseline model again it's not a perfect
example I was not going for good now
it's just something that you can easily
use random forest classifier because we
have top 5 it's like from 0 & 1 if it is
and zero is not so we have several
tables you can imagine data is kept in
SQL so the driver the race's table which
has on explanation when it was what
amount of rounds sir good idea I'm not
exactly sure what it is name is being
encoded because there is like Australian
mo naku and stuff like that and it's
categorical values so for easiness of
work for the model we've encoded it on
the github you can see the raw data and
role model so you can check it out and
work with it as well and standings is
the combined table that shows when what
was happening whoops
so what if we want to predict if the
pilot was in the top X in our case and
top 5 for the race what can we put in
into the model so it's a drive ID which
will for instance replace the driver
name and all the specifics date of
births nationality race ID like where he
was taking part in name of the race or a
name or even of the race as well for
instance if it's true maja people just
assume that its genetic you are a good
racer and the features would be like
this is the raw data the features would
be driver ID date of birth split into
the year and months nationality finds us
as a categorical value again the race ID
is an integer date of the race split
into year and once again and named
either of the race like let's go let's
go with the race for a model to work I
took psychic line classifier so it needs
one table to be put in it cannot take
different sources differently it should
be one input so we put it into simple
model DF which contains every data we
need from the tables you saw before
and the model was at 91% it's a really
small data set and it's pretty simple
and the model is like random forests in
general quite good at generalization and
caching the features so it's ok it's
good but can we do better so the
features that you would think of would
be how old was the driver when he took
first part in this race or how long did
he take a pause between the races was he
taking how many races before was he
participating in all those features that
you can can come up with as a domain
expert are quite annoying to create for
instance this is called feature
engineering and it can be done
automatically or manually manually is a
domain knowledge where you can even
unite outside sources of the data to
bring them in and to provide the model
with more insights and automatic
approach I will be demonstrating now so
yeah manual features I've already called
and I will be presenting feature tools
library which is quite popular right now
and has really neat default settings if
you want to tinker more and spend some
time playing with it you can get really
amazing results but in this presentation
we will go with default so anybody can
just start it and get something out the
way feature tools works it works on SQL
table so it's joining them joining the
columns and does sound transformation
that are pretty fine the core of the
library you need to create an entity set
which would be just the use case you're
creating then you provide the tables by
entity say it from this entity entity
from data frame you provide also the
columns you provide the types of the
columns so that certain operations are
not applied to some homes that does not
make sense to operate on for instance
unique number of IDs like yeah thank you
it is unique already and then you need
to specify the connections between the
tables they currently work one on one
so if you have a table with multiple
foreign keys you might run into really
weird features they still might work but
it's not something a real human will
come up with so the suggested line of
behavior is to cascade wise connect them
in this case drivers and standings are
connected by Drive ID and races and
standings are connected by race ID
connections should be unique like in any
SQL table its desired then we create the
feature matrix and the future
definitions feature matrix is just a
data frame with all the additional
columns
I think I'm stepping on something okay
you create a data frame out of all the
data you have and just column wise
combination and weird magic done to it
this is default setting you can do way
more you can specify what transformation
to apply data transformation what depths
you use normally you don't go beyond - I
was just toying around with for normally
it goes like how many transformation to
apply to and one column two columns and
so forth so it can be up to ten or even
more which again is not humanly
understandable anymore so for instance
like unique sum of log of square root of
something else so it might make sense my
not so the xre accuracy actually of the
very same model but with all the columns
now is increased by 17% no 17 7.1 points
wait 10 % about 10% so it is better but
we get about 33 features in from
original 7 and it's you can see some
limited feature importance of the model
and you can see that mode of standing
races of the year is kind of weird so
these are all generated features and
they are having quite a small weight to
the model so this are the features that
were generated
and some of them are like what a help I
do not think that this will work and
what can you do you can start doing
feature selection and the more features
you have the better your future
selection will get it also will become
very cumbersome but it will work better
once you have two more to work with
why feature your selection is important
it reduces overfitting which is a big
problem you can so over fit your model
that it's just not usable anymore and
this is normally what people try to
avoid and you don't need it improves
accuracy as there are two connected and
it also reduces training time the more
features you have the more data you have
the more iterations a model needs to
actually learn the patterns if you have
time money and hardware cool but it's
not always the case especially if you
want to wrap up the prototype so how to
we can do manual feature selections
again based on the domain knowledge or
certain estimators that models provide
for instance weights that contribute to
the model we can just set a cutoff
that's saying above 12 0.1 is something
really that means something to the model
otherwise just drop it or we can try to
automatically try to use automatic
systems for that the semi manual
approach would be to use something from
scikit-learn as well but set the
threshold to a certain degree for
instance we can ask scikit-learn to have
model fit and then it will automatically
discard all the columns that it doesn't
think it needs to you can just use
default value but you can also set your
own again it's this same situation where
you say that the weight should be above
certain threshold there is a good
article on this so there is a good
article on this you can follow the link
and it has more in-depth detail example
on every three examples so this would be
select from model which is automatic one
you provide the training set you provide
your model which is the parameter on the
second line so this is our classifier
and psychic learns it decreases the
amount of features that the model
consumes from such as v2 11 I must say
the accuracy was not better though but
you can equate expect that that in
general your accuracy on a test set will
increase with the amount of data you fit
in and also amount of features because
you are overfitting but on the training
set and your own validation set you will
be not succeeding so right now we see a
different picture for this 11 instances
or 11 features ok so automatic but not
good enough what else can we do we can
do a hit map it's a pre model training
feature selection we can create a heat
map or correlation of all the features
with each other and set a certain
threshold to exclude them if there are
Lin correlated find sense everything
about above 0.5 is kind of weird or 0.7
so it's somewhat domain knowledge and
expertise knowledge as well but you want
to do it automated ok in this
presentation I want to show you a teapot
teapot is actually not only feature
selection automation its automation of
the whole pipeline overall rather of a
big chunk of it it utilizes genetic
algorithms to try to create some really
weird feature combinations as well as
tuning hyper parameters of the model as
well as choosing the best model for you
if you go with the full set of the
features of this library so this is what
you can find on the teapot documentation
so you can see again you have a raw data
and will data cleaning or data
processing pre-processing and then
feature selection feature engineering
feature construction
and the model are kind of in a circle
and permit organization technically
goals also into this circle so the big
problem with this is it runs everything
from data input to output and create the
pipeline for you like psychic pipeline
if you have ever seen those in an
additional file and you can just run
this file and it will execute it again
and create the mall itself the problem
is it's not guaranteed to have the very
same result on the very same data
because of different genetic mutations
it introduces it is limited because it
uses cross-validation as its estimator
for models comparing those and for me
for quite a small amount of data we are
talking about less than thousand rows it
ran fold that much segments that many
seconds I increased the amount of data
up to three thousand rows and it was
running for two hours so you can imagine
why it's happening because it's trying
everything that a human would not even
touch out because it has no sense of
yeah this feature does not make sense
how even I would produce it but again
for someone who has no idea how to
select it or just wants to try it out I
think it's a really cool place to start
so the auto machine learning
classification that was created I was
explicitly I've explicitly chosen the
random forest classifier that it once
actually only once suggested it's only
performed at this accuracy level which
is again worse than our starting model
so you have to think twice if you want
to incorporate it the limitations so
teapot is so-called Auto ml automatic
machine learning pipeline it has a
couple of limitation it requires time as
you saw it has very high complexity and
it's less under control because the
whole process you can't say stop there
to in this parameter instead of that one
that continued it results might differ
so you might not even introduce for some
reason you just triggered the run again
and you got a different model
so do you deploy the new model are you
okay with your old one so what do you do
especially the cross-validation or any
other estimator that you can use is the
same there are a lot of questions about
the results it produces less control as
an overall and new features required the
whole pipeline run meaning the new model
can be suggested to the new features
which is again it's rather unstable
thing to use on production so this is
basically it what I wanted to show you
today with steel they are water mighty
automative or automated feature your
engineering feature selection and the
whole machine learning process is still
kind of sloppy it is possible but if you
have a people that can get into the core
of this programs and for instance have a
control by stopping the run of this
programs at certain phase like model
creation and then redirecting to a
certain model or fixing the amount of
features or fixing the amount of
parameters that can tweak this specific
library is not there yet but Google and
IBM rolled out recently their own auto
ml libraries that are worth checking out
the reason you need automation in this
thing's is manual processes are not
scalable and they are not scalable in
terms of human power and time needed
because every feature that is being
created might not play well with the
others features it might be collinear
and you might not even notice that
before you run the test or before you
put it onto production also you might
not know whether this feature is easy to
come by
if you are creating a machine learning
on request like you want to have a
prediction for a racer but you don't
know his name for some reason or you
don't know the year he was born in so
this model becomes
unusable and when you're training it
manually you have control over such
things so yeah this is what I wanted to
present you today about automatic
feature engineering and selection thank
you very much okay I think it's pretty
awesome so I have a question so because
there's always a yes because stuff has a
question I've seen you it's like there's
a lot of discussions going on about that
data and data science is basically
automating humans and your data engineer
data science do you feel threatened by
Auto ml or do you think it's a tool it
is a tool for instance there are use
cases when you need to automate your
workflow to be able to concentrate on
the cool things on the other hand it's
just so bad
so I'm not feel threatened at all yeah
so human expertise is so far always
better because of how humans can work
only humans can create something new
some completely new concept and
introduce really valuable features into
the model if it's required in comparison
to this models even if they use really
advanced algorithms like alright I
forgot the name the mutations and they
introduced the features it's still very
small changes and it's not able to by
chance combine two completely different
sources that's never seen so in this
case it is a cool thing to play around
to test ideas to maybe even automate
certain part of your work like
unwrapping time stamps like creating
low-level simple features that you don't
want to skip or spend your time on but
if you want to achieve really good
results no zombies read narrow
yeah my question was mostly like autumn
is pretty cheap as an algorithm right
it's just plain evolution with epochs
and very cheaply implemented in a sense
of what it knows about it features
themselves so the generation aspect of
behind it is like pretty pretty cheap I
don't know a couple weeks ago there was
like a new paper released called waited
massive new networks which was basically
using the approach of need or need based
algorithms and trying to combine and
with the idea that they are wait
acrostics so that the layers in between
from speaking of autumn L it is able to
have something Xen and layer so lsdm
layers on top like that and combined and
basically it only learns X or all the
time so that's why it performs the worst
also bad and the idea behind need and
you had need was that the evolutionary
algorithm is aware of like the features
themselves like in a sense that it knows
the relations between the time
sensitivity and stuff like that and my
question is mostly whether you try it
out to compare for example like wait
agnostic new networks or meet other
algorithms with Auto and I didn't go the
deep like I don't think this automative
approach is like my idea was to show
simple steps can be automated the
problem with the more complex model you
have the more control you need over your
to mention steps as well like feature
preparations with neural networks you
need more map movers more data second
the data might be not that linear
connected to each other like columns
should not be very obviously connected I
mean the reason you use neural networks
as already you want to learn something
cool so I haven't compared those I think
this are stupid ones rather they are
rather random combination of features
it's might work
it might not work but there is no
guarantee and the advanced models that
you suggest that will mostly always
outperform
algorithms that come out of this one
right so thank you very much
[Applause]